the key is let your kid get injured so
then they'll be in a cast for six months
that's your only hope of having a break
then they're on the couch you're golded
I have this and they've learned a
valuable lesson when is the last time
you saw a child in a cast oh my God it
like doesn't even happen no because the
uh the hovering the protection do you
remember we had a you coddle if you
coddle your child through their I read
this great article it's called let him
climb the tree ooh and what it talks
about is if you don't let your child
climb the tree they will never learn or
respect um gra injury mm or risk and
they become risk averse because they
don't understand risk and that's why you
have the highest killer of teenagers is
reckless driving whoa reckless driving
for teenage boys and the reason is is
because they don't understand risk they
don't understand it because they never
got to climb the tree when you climb the
tree you learn you get up there and
you're like oh I'm too high I'm coming
back down or you fall or you you know
you you just get a perspective right and
and we we hurt now yes we don't let them
climb the tree the stakes being low
instead of when you're going 80 miles
hour because when you learn early that
there's risk to we used to build ramps
and jump our bikes over the ramps and do
something and of course you know people
would get hurt people break their ankles
break their wrists do you remember slip
and slides of course we would just throw
hurl ourselves yes at 100 miles hour we
used to P up Olive on it oh yeah oh even
yeah even dawn we used
Dawn and we and you would like slick as
snot I mean yeah and then you'd go off
think maybe we should take the rocks out
from underneath and you'd hit the grass
I'd have grass Burns do you remember the
flexible flyer sled yes that was it had
two like it was like a a railroad track
it was two metal bars and we used to do
Chinese downhills that's what it was
called back then you know anybody it was
called a Chinese downhill it was where
everybody started real estate in
America and they spread a virus the W
lab uh we uh uh everybody would run so
you have like 12 to 15 kids running with
their SL and you all start at the same
time and as you went down it was a
massive you're trying to flip everybody
knock everybody off you're running into
each other and people were just like end
overend cartwheel it was a melee and
every get to the bottom whoever was you
know one one and and then everybody
reminisce about the stories go back up
and do it again none of those kids
gotten died in car accidents later
that's right you know what I mean that's
right we crashed them but we didn't die
there's a great book called hunt gather
parent and I just finished reading it
and it's about it's not your job to
entertain your kid so so many times like
I need to take you to the escapades and
I no it's like take the kid to do all
the boring things that you have to do on
a daily basis and it's their job to be
interesting it's not your job to be tap
dancing yeah you know I remember that my
dad always had this theory he was like
I'd rather you get learn in here than
out there yeah you know my mom one time
I've told the story before but she
slapped me across the face when I was 11
years old I said something that I should
not have said to her and she smacked me
across the face and it I I was as I was
hitting the wall I was so grateful cuz
like I would have done that somewhere
else and it would have been way worse
you know it's our job to be harder on
our kids a little bit well that's what I
wrestle with with with my boy and he's
fine you know he's a good he's a very
he's a wonderful child but I do you know
I think our we have to uh make them
resilient we have to give them that
resiliency we have to because they're
going everybody's going to hit adversity
we're all going to hit it everybody does
there's no way to avoid it nobody gets
out here warn kids also when you give a
kid a warning this is dangerous it just
makes them more like when you're like
don't touch the light socket you're like
well now I got to go touch put my finger
in the light socket yeah why not now you
just I wouldn't even have thought to put
my finger in that before that's a human
thing too I think if says don't do that
you're like like why not and if they
can't give you satisfactory answer
you're like well I need to find out for
myself and when I go with my friends to
the um playgrounds now which by the way
are all made of plastic our and they're
on like a mushy yeah uh they cut up
tires they shred tires so it's a big
it's a rubbery foamy cushy thing ours
was like a asphalt asph gravel and
little pieces of gravel like on top and
steel remember the rusted steel it was
scaffolding there was like a there was a
what was the monkey bars was just
scaffolding it scaffolding with edges
and do you remember the chain length
pirate chain you would just climb a
rusty chain yeah I also remember the
bigger kids that would be like what are
you doing then muscle you the bullies
and you'd have to deal you had to
negotiate that yep yep yep and what what
that meant was we'd ride our bikes up
there the older kids were there we come
back later that's you just you learn how
to make choices you know we're going to
go over there and go we're here to play
too no no no no no you're going to get
an ass whooping remember the everything
was so rickety the merry goout was
always so rickety the and janky it was
always off-kilter always and someone
always just like I was like you're like
where did Jimmy go just underneath and
then um there was just so much scary but
I see my girlfriends with their kids and
they're like be careful don't get on
that and be careful that's dangerous and
that's and it's just like it's a
disservice I see the kid looking at
their parent like why did you bring me
here if it's so D I can't play now I'm
confused and they're just in this
general anxiety instead of let them go
let them go and then when they're
actually in some kind of danger that's
when you interview right of course
you're not going to sit no one's going
to sit there and allow the child to be
hurt M but let them let them run a muck
and when they bang their head they're
going to come to you crying and guess
what they may have a little knot on
their head you you rub it you love them
up and then you let them play again and
guess what they're going to figure this
stuff out and they're going to be okay
but if you deny them the opportunity to
climb that tree you're setting up a
teenage bomb advice for raising a boy
advice for raising a boy uh you got to
let him be a boy you know what that's
the big one you don't always stop him
like boys are rambunctious boys are
mischievous I'll never forget the day my
son walked out of the his bedroom he was
probably four and he goes what is this
or what is this made out of and I was
like metal it was some metal part to a
like it looked like a hinge and and I I
go it's metal he goes why I said and I
said why why he goes because I can't
break it and then he went back in his
room
that's just I was like oh that's the
that's what's up today that's the reason
I need to figure out why I can't break
something yeah he came back what is this
or what's this made out of metal I said
why son he's like I can't break it and
he was frustrated went back in this is
what happens with boys they pick stuff
up and they're like huh he took a bite
out of a club cracker one time and it he
gripped it like a gun and was just doing
this and he was four years old like he
hadn't been exposed to like Rambo movies
or Call of Duty he just instinctively
bit into a cracker and it kind of had a
shap and he started shooting people with
his Club cracker this is the stuff that
happens with boys